well another extremely sort of
you know
liberation-inducing woman comes to mind
is madonna is it true
that express yourself
was written about you it would be weird
for me to say that
if it weren't true that she said it to
me that's crazy i mean she said it to
everyone
i don't know
is she possible you are really good
friends with her okay we were super
tight at that moment she was the one who
was just broken up with shawn i had just
broken up with matthew i was ooh
and she threw a party for me and she was
yeah i mean that is that's good that's
my polaroid that's a good time that's
the stripper party that she threw for me
at canal bar where she had the the
waiter start to strip to time of july oh
my god and that had me down it goes
really so wild okay so here she was like
saying to me like you know being that
girlfriend that you know everyone needs
a girlfriend who can tell you you did
the right thing or it's gonna be okay
you'll get someone else or whatever and
then i was living in laurel canyon
because i remember where i was and so
i'm in the log cabin carrie fisher's log
cabin in laurel canyon and she said hey
i just did a song come into my she was
like i'm she had a mercedes like what
are those old two-door mercedes oh it's
like an sl like the yeah the old ones
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i said well let's listen in here she
goes no my sound system's better so we
get in the car she closes the door and
she plays it for me and she said
i wrote this you inspired me
so she's never said it publicly i and i
actually wrote her recently and i said i
wrote about you in my book is this true
and i choose like send it to me um okay
tom cruise yes
you
were doing a screen test with him
and was there something about a cocktail
for cocktail
how did that go what was tom cruise like
well i was friends with tom cruise i met
him at a no nukes rally i was kind i
felt like his older sister you know what
i mean like he was guessing me for
relationship advice and stuff like that
so
we go to the screen test and i'm like
okay here's my old friend so then we
have to do the bed scene some love scene
and it's a chemistry read they're trying
to see how hot you are together and feel
that
and i just couldn't stop laughing
the whole time
and the more i laughed the more mad he
got
until finally the director was okay i
think we're done here and i was like i'm
sorry
let's try again
when you get those giggles you get the
giggles but what's so cute is i hear a
story like that and i think about the
moment that patrick swayze again down
your arm and that giggle is something
that we all love so much it's a part of
cinema history it's the cutest most
endearing sweet moment
of that movie
so
thank god for your giggle
you know i'm ticklish
i am just i'm really glad that you
decided to
because i i am a work in progress i want
to figure things out i've been
struggling every day to grow up it turns
out growing up it's not overrated i
really like it it's amazing it gets
better and better exponentially that's
the crazy part because you talk about my
you know early life and all my
adventures and stuff
i was crazy and unhappy
i was so crazy and so unhappy and it
looks like
very exciting and fun which it was but
what happens is
i was like spinning out
and it wasn't till it all just
fell apart that i started to understand
who i was and what made me happy that
book is my truth it's my story and i
welcome anyone
to write their own story and i welcome
anyone in the book to write their story
because that's what what we have
right so glad you share it and encourage
us all
and i love that you talk about the
second half of a woman's life can also
be the best part also it is i agree well
thank you so much for coming here and
talking about this amazing book
your new memoir out of the corner is out
now and thank you for all these fun
yummy details and guess what everyone in
the audience is getting a book
and
i thank
your publishers and our producers for
being able to do that
out of the corner
i'll be in a corner with you any day
i'll keep myself there
[Applause]
[Music]